welcome to this video round form the
candidates tournament it's a very
interesting tournament so far many
interesting fighting games and the game
we're going to see now is so far
probably the most spectacular
complicated a game so you guy you're
going to witness a real battle here and
it's of very big importance for the
further cause of the tournament as we
see Aronian pre-tournament
favorite until this game on 50% against
Whitlam who's on +1 and he really had
some good chances to be Kramnik in round
3 but didn't didn't take those chances
just to fall to a miracle defense so
very important game let's see what
happens aronia playing 1.d4 which guy
can't call it a surprise his main move
but recently very often if he suspected
that the opponent is going for the grid
thought he was playing a c4 or Knight f3
the entire group thought move orders I
won't go to the opening I want to talk
so much about the opening this game
because it's it's just so terribly
complicated later this is going to be a
three-hour video if I do an opening
server in it okay we have the the normal
let's say Grunwald sweet la sticks to
his guns he's not going to surprise
Aronian he'll place what he always plays
since his childhood so we get the main
line Grune fault Ronia plays rook b1
here he has tried on quite a number of
lines against the green felt he has
played with Bishop e3 here instead of
rupee one he played an early Bishop g5
all kinds of lines he switched back and
forth between different approaches but
this is something that Villa could
expect
and I will refer I will show you much
later in the game why that is rupee one
yeah okay black castles Bishop e2 one
important point of this rupee ones is
that if black plays Knight c6 here on
the move before white has the good reply
d5 this is an important point check to
you have the rook removed from the scope
of this Bishop this is a playable on a
playable line for for black but it's
considered somewhat risky um the
absolute main line is what's witless
doing boy he took giant Queen a5 check
this is by far the most principled way
to play
just grabbing this pawn white can also
try to keep the pawn but this is
considered to be a rather rather meek
and comparison this typical endgame
doesn't hold many various so black okay
Bishop d2 Queen takes a to castles and
here that's a big big crossroads this
position has been reached
I don't know I would need to look it up
probably thousands of times not not sure
but we were talking about a couple
hundred - tower - to thousands of games
it's the critical the the starting point
for the critical line in the rook p1
guro tablet can play many things Bishop
g4 for example under a five speed allah
has played all kinds of museum he's
going for b6 which probably was no
surprise i means villa had played this
before even last year in the candidates
yet one game with b6 i didn't look it up
i know that he played it in the
candidates but i'm not quite sure
against against whom i think it moved
was read job offer I'm not quite sure
but he had played it before so
certainly something that the Rohingya
Nam must have take care of in his
preparation and also this is very
interesting this p6 move was also played
last year in the Beijing mine sports
event by exam degree shock yeah why is
this so especially important grease
shock is known to be close friends with
swedeland and they have worked together
as seconds for each other for quite a
number of years
so if grease shock is playing such a
critical line it's very likely that he
had somehow shared information with
swindler so something that Aronian must
have looked that he played Quincy won
and tending the specialty phone booth
and well the thing is this is this
opening is obviously very sharp White
has got a good center that is not so
easily attacked but he has sacrificed of
course the a pond which means that the
black has already made plan here just
push the apron if everything else fails
you said that this pawn to push and yeah
black you must be very precise to
survive the initiative that is going to
unfold in the center the same time of
course you have this awkward Queen oops
this awkward Queen on a 2 that you
always we are constantly need to worry
about ok let's let's look what happened
I'll just put this on the board it has
been played numerous times and if I go
to the subtleties here we never get
anywhere in the video rookie one
covering eform rook c8 attacking whites
Queen 20 back Queen c2 Queen e2 and
knight c6 exactly here we add a position
that has been played in the mentioned
game Aronian against
in Beijing last year and TM in this game
and the mind to this mind mind games
right I only had played e5 which didn't
feel so critical after 98 so what was
exactly it says preparation you played
Bishop d3 Queen a - Bishop c4 Queen a4
and Bishop b3 all this is known very
much knowing from games back in the in
the 90s
there should be three between a three
this is a new move bus Willowbrook Queen
a6 had been played and some some known
games and in fact in those games we see
motifs that happened later in our main
game after Queen a6 there was for
instance there were games with Queen III
Knight e5 and Bishop
f7 and this turned out to be
exceptionally dangerous for black King
f7 nagi-chan check King g8 and now Queen
to - to h3 attacking here and attending
Queen e6 yeah and this was after age 696
a very very dangerous attack that black
didn't manage to survive in
games that have been played in the 90s
so this sacrifice on f7 is a very
well-known motif and after Queen a3 that
is what's within the plate we come to
very important point of this game of
course aronia now if you look at this he
had spent already 31 minutes to put this
on the board amazingly enough it was
really surprising to see because as I
told you the the background story and
what happened in games before it was
very much to expect it to expect that to
get that they get this position on the
board um yeah I really don't know I mean
it's Villa is playing the goon fat all
the time and he had experience with this
slide there was this crucial game
very young tricky how to tell why
Aronian didn't play this any quicker
okay anyway look at this position we
remember the the sacrifice on f7 yeah in
fact after a while check Aronian really
took on f7 so we got this this wild
right help us now Bishop takes f7 is
actually the only way really to to get
something serious going in this in this
position if black is given time like
something like that for example to allow
that then it's not clear where White's
compensation is you always have
something a bit of compensation but is
it enough probably not well Aronian
decided to sacrifice them and to be
honest this is the kind of move you if
you calculate it and you don't see that
there's anything wrong with it if you
want to win this tournament you need to
play like that you cannot
play this kind of salsa moves and hope
to to win games because the opponent is
playing some nonsense you need to take
some risks and yeah show - yeah - yeah -
have some guts to do to attack
no Bishop f7 was played King takes
checkered Queen c4 check swindler
obviously had this prepared right I mean
he played this quickly I mean this is
they are not there aren't any
alternatives anyway but it was of course
aware of the sacrifice so Quincy for
check let's start to examine what's
going on here in fact here black only
has one move from that he can play and
it played this quickly black must play
in success the only move from that not
loses out right
if you move let's start with looking at
thought on too skinny evade it's very
easily dismissed by nigt with this made
threat and yeah there's simply simply
nothing I can do him you can return the
piece in various ways with a losing
position let's say like that
check check check
and here boy what can just take him and
win easily he's just he just has a
deadly attack and then no it's an extra
point even so King evaders losing very
simply King EA it is also losing
checking with the check
Bishop f8 to save this piece and now
Knight g5 is a winning move this I think
also d5 winning but not g5 is the
easiest and tending this intending that
it's it's getting really ugly
also there is d5 if like moves the
knight let's say here you have also
Knight e5 also a possible win so this
was I mean besides the fact that he had
it prepared
yeah it's easy to see that e 6 is the
only move and then if you know oh-kayyy
6 you need to play Knight g5 check you
see that white really has a substantial
attack growing okay check to the King it
only has one square to v8 yeah this is
there an easily dismissed completely in
logical as well and this is of course
exact leading to the famous check check
check late famous smothered mate so
again only one move to e8 yeah and here
in fact in fact white has a choice it's
it's clear that you need to do something
direct with the pawn on e6 you need to
capture only six but how would you
capture is actually not self-evident in
the game Aronian took only six with the
night we can also look at some in takes
no Queen takes has some one yeah one
drawback in a way it is playable the
displayable no doubt about that but it
has one drawback after Queen seven which
is the only move 97 we should be for us
very simple winning for white so Queen
e7 and here yeah white really does not
have much choice
Queen g8 as the way to go check yeah and
here the the bad thing is from a
practical point of view black now has
two moves and it's not clear that yeah
let's start with that King be seven
after King g7 white probably needs to
play Queen d5 check and after King 8 we
will get up sorry I'm I'm wrong 26 I
went to the from wrong line in my notes
26 actually after that we are very
likely to have check a repetition coming
check to DVD v8 from that is
exceptionally risky if from yeah if not
downright bad I mean risky is probably a
bit too friendly
yeah and in addition one problem for
widest this King 7 means you probably
have to take the draw but there's also
Bishop f8 it's not the most
natural-looking when the world but it's
not clear if White has got anything
great against it to be honest I didn't
manage to find a good continuation
it seems to be playable it's not like
it's it's totally crazy but I didn't
find anything great I mean the computer
gives completely strange lines like a
Bishop III for example Knight takes d4
and here it wants to play I mean this is
also not completely ridiculous let's say
F form
yeah but it's not like why this is
winning easily or anything you might get
two positions where it will be some sort
of perpetual check our repetition but
it's not really convincing and the
biggest problem from a practical point
of view is it's very likely that in this
position black will take lots of time
and think okay King d7 is probably a
draw and I can maybe plank push-up evade
you sort of yeah giving like control
over what what's happening this this
draw fights to continuing and okay he
went for Knight takes c6 and this is I
think also objectively the better move
because it sets from far more problems
yeah
now came Swilly are now played Queen to
e7
this is the only map maybe it's the only
move it's very difficult to do too
yeah to conclude something with some
sort of certainty here because it's so
complicated white obviously attacks the
bishop and Queen e7
protected yeah can you move the bishop
hmm yeah
Bishop h8 for example is a move that the
computer initially suggests but yeah
it's it's very risky White has an
interesting reply can play Knight to c5
very interesting move Queen g8 as
possible queenie success move the bishop
is hanging it looks terribly dangerous i
mean probably after seeing that move I
would maybe start to start to stop
calculations okay maybe 97 now this is
something that black needs to needs to
check it covers g8 it covers this me
this check and give some sort of
coordination but white can attack
continue to attack with the move like
Bishop g5 VM note that black can never
really take this is even leading to
forced made already yeah after this what
what should like do Amy can try
something like this
but then there's at least e5 with a was
a substantial attack it's very hard to
tell I mean it looks immensely risky I
mean and completely unnatural to be
honest
Queen e7 I think is the more human and
probably just just better news yeah okay
this was played rather quickly after the
sacrifice and now check Aronian after
some consideration took on g7 it's of
course another critical position and
because 97 is something that is young
it's very committal of course to give up
your very strong looking at night on e6
it's just a very attractive piece of
course what else is there yeah there is
the move d5 which I think certainly was
considered 94 is the best reply to that
here and now we come to a very funny
sequence a Q&A for check and of course
this is hanging so b5 must be played we
cannot just just move here and give this
away so b5 and now White has no choice
he needs to take here check now white is
a look down look for two points but note
that it's it's very tricky the King
needs to move now this is entirely a
playable check no something like that
check wins the Queen and we probably
made in short order as well maybe that's
even Roxy one maid or something it's
it's completely lost so like here needs
to move the King to f7 it's the only
move and after that the game yeah just
just continues and it's there are
various ideas maybe the most the
cleanest idea for white is just take
King takes and d6 yeah why does the rook
down but look at this the specifics of
the position make it very difficult for
black now to play the queen is attacked
where should it go but still keeping the
bishop on b7 yeah you can suggest this
move but look at this these happen with
the tempo and there's this bishop coming
up into the game so you can try to play
this type of position but it looks like
it looks suicidal for black white can
also just pick up the piece if he has
taken care about the main threat maybe a
move like f3 is interesting attending
Queen to him and taking very very tough
to play for black if not unplayable to
be honest um probably here the easiest
is to just take him
Quinta sb7 and then to return him chant
something like that can easily result in
a repetition with the draw
it's just exceptionally sharp but I
think it's very likely that Aronian even
calculated this because it's white
simply has no big alternatives if he
moves the Queen some wells black will
just take his six and has nothing to
fear so it's probable probably he saw
that and thought okay I cannot fight for
win with this so he went for the capture
Queen takes and he played Bishop c3
young I was also looking at Queenie City
check just the Captain Obvious move but
okay it needs to be checked similarly to
before here again there's Queenie 7 and
it's very question so if this is check
more than then a draw this is a kind of
repetitions it's a it's not yeah look at
this this is simply too risky you can
try but it's very risky Bishop before
Queenie six and Queen back yeah and g5
will come Queen g3 with an exceptionally
strong attack it probably will end in a
draw by by repetition if white gives
this check however there is of course 97
to check instead of Queenie 7
yeah what's happening after this move
it's impossible of course to - were to
analyze - to some sort of conclusion
it's it's very very difficult but let's
consider for a while g5 yeah White has
just one point for the piece but he has
of course he's got those this point do
the bishop can come into the game on
those two mostly those two critical
squares and of course black has
I really am yeah hampered coordination
it's very very difficult to play after
d5 here for example somewhat
normal-looking moves like Queen f7 is is
alright losing because of Queen e5 the
Queen here cannot be attacked and white
will just play those two moves and win
it it's just it's just toast I was a bit
a bit surprised as well but it's just
just a flat-out win um if black tries to
defend in another way let's say Roxy -
no very logical active move it might
continue like that this is not a fast
line I'm just showing a line that I was
able to work out together with the
engine would be d1 rook e8 to assist in
defense Queen to h3 yeah I'm making some
yeah getting the Queen out of the way of
the pawns and possibly intending Bishop
h6 at the right moment it's a queen e5
Queen takes h7 and here funny defense
Bishop takes d5
the point is 85/50 - quite quite cute
and black is even even better so white
cannot cannot take but you can play this
move Bishop c4 for example yeah and how
is this going to end
yeah you may be may be guessing this
already it can easily end in a draw
because of the exposed black king OOP
dat niet Jensen Queen Eason Chan t1
check yeah and this is all completely
forced check check
you know it will end in a draw
check like that for example um it's it's
not a fast line and just try to show
what types of positions we we might get
queenie 6 was an alternative for sure
but i guess it's very large and that
queenie 7 would have happened check with
this drawn and chania didn't want to
allow a draw so easily i guess he played
Bishop to c3 and here
sevilla whoa I only had spent eight
minutes for all this we are moved 26
yeah I mean he's got 14 moves left to
make and still has almost all of his
time it's a sign how deep the
preparation was and it wasn't difficult
to play the the last couple of moves as
they were completely forced from blacks
point of view and probably still part of
the preparation yeah here it's a very
critical situation look at this witness
on one one hour 25 left and his next
move he played ninety eight and he
spends more than fifty minutes on that
yeah and here it's very critical because
now the the course of the game could
have been changed dramatically his villa
had an option to basically in my mind to
end the game in a way he could have
played Knight takes d4 just a technical
solution the point is that it's
discovered to take on the queen of
course yeah white has to take not much
else Queen takes bishop takes and oopsie
form bishop a one young and here okay
black cannot take this is check easy to
see we lose the bishop yeah and in this
position on swedeland the press
conference said that after i think he
mentioned king the seven
not quite sure he didn't mention Bishop
c6 which is the computers top choice
he thought that after King d7 f3 white
is very very slightly better which I
find really surprising I mean I'm almost
shocked because I really thought that if
anyone's what comes to her head would be
black with the two passports but okay
it's clear that the pawns are not going
anywhere at the moment and maybe I'm
completely wrong about this I mean it's
really obviously it's the better player
but it seems strange to me I mean I
think black really shouldn't have any
problem whatsoever so to at least get it
Rowand and I think instead of king D 7
the computer move Bishop c6 is indeed
better rather sure about that
the idea is to quickly get B 585 in and
I believe that white is almost forced to
quickly play rook c1 and get to get this
rook exchanged if Black gets rolling
with b5 and 85 he is just better I'm
pretty sure and I really don't see why
black should have any sort of trouble
here so it would be interesting to know
I only know ass witless statement from
the press conference and if he indeed
believe that he has some trouble here
then I understand maybe why it didn't
play 94 okay the thing is also look at
the position I mean black is a piece up
for a pawn and he is about it's about an
hour every advantage on the clock and it
seems like somehow Aronian didn't
prepare that for some reason so he's on
his own unit you cannot really suspect
that you in some sort of yeah monster
preparation that Aronian just took one
hour to put on the board it's of course
very tempting to continue the game with
a piece up and in a way but it's also
quite risky and we see rather quickly
that it's
yeah that black really must be super
precise and defense after what he played
now I played 98 you know a checking of
the Queen and if you're not taking on
before this is probably the best move as
well so yeah it's it's the fighting
decision I mean Knight takes d4 has a
very high likelihood and ended ending in
a draw but this is not what what he did
I mean this deserves to be a yeah this
deserves some respect
anyway he wants to fight on and let's
see what what happens 98 um the divine
play my quite sure Queen Queen wisteria
Queen b3 okay the Queen was attacked and
now rook c7 and that's also very
sensible move the computer also suggests
rook takes c3 here the exchange
sacrifice acknowledging the fact that
this bishop will get will be a very very
strong piece in the future however this
is I believe a continuation that the
human player is very unlikely to play
simply because white retains this pawn
duo in the center and will will have
strong initiative anyway maybe it's a
good way to play but it's very very
strange for a human to do at this point
to sacrifice the exchange
he played rook system and I think it's
perfectly okay I'm not saying that this
was a mistake to play rook system okay
Bishop a1 very interesting move he gets
out of this exposed square he wants to
play d5 but at the moment this was
obviously a big mistake
so Bishop a1 is the prep move for d5 so
white is attacking here with a piece
down but he's not rushing things him
what he needs to do is to yeah well keep
all pieces on the board and try to
advance the center deep
of e5 e6 d6 these pawns must roll
forward while keeping all pieces on and
this is in fact very very difficult for
black to to counter
I mean understands with less desire to
fight but to be honest if I would
absolutely hate to be black here this
position because you need to be so
precise and then defense it's yeah it's
very very hard to play okay he played
rook a to c8 doubling on the C file it's
certainly a move that has a look of
logic to it and so it makes some sense
um
computer funny enough even suggests 96
yeah which looks completely crazy to be
honest something like that but yeah just
just look at this type of position isn't
this isn't this very uncomfortable for
black the Queen is saying needs to move
then let's say rook here and f4 f5 e v
it's just so it's much easier for white
to attack then for black to coordinate
the defense iam yeah well he played rook
AC 8 and d5 of course yeah and this pawn
wedge is very strong it keeps those
squares under control and black does not
have any any easy move here yeah of
course it's where the temple the queen
is attacked and it moves to 27 Queen B 2
tending to invade on edge 827 is blacks
reply yeah and you you can consider
other moves at various stages um but
it's it keeps it's always this position
where white slowly will push the pawns
forward and this kind of attacks are
often much more difficult to defend
against then those very em
the director text the text that um can
be sometimes just resolved and defended
against by pure calculation this is very
difficult here because white is just
pushing everything slowly forward he can
also make here their prep move and you
have delay things it's not like he needs
to be super quick about about his
advance okay if I of rooks II to check
and queen b5 check this was played yeah
and here we come to UM to a key point of
course it's a check and black what
should like do miss got two ways to play
he can play Queen d7 which essentially I
turns the piece or he can move the king
if we look at the King move into evade
it must conclude that this also gives
white excellent attacking play and
various continuations are possible white
can play a six this is a very direct way
of course Knight to d6 and queen a4
intending to even grab here yeah this
can can do to a very weird position
where black actually has a
counter-attack against them f2 after
cruciate rook c8 Queen a7 Roxy to this
could have could could for example end
in a draw very rare draw but yeah but it
can happen in fact what I do believe is
white probably shouldn't play is six so
quickly it's an interesting alternative
to after the Queen has yet driven the
King to evade to maybe return with the
Queen and maybe even intend to switch it
all the way to age three it's very
tricky to analyze this position
possible of just the possible
continuation let's say after Queen d3
like black plays rook to to c5 attacking
this Queen 8 3 and here the computer
suggests an interesting defense and I
actually do believe that this is a good
defense he wants to take on d5 it's very
yeah very rare to on the rear to
understand this but rook takes d5 yeah
and then at first you think okay what's
the point yeah yeah
the point is that black now has an
amazing move he's got Knight g5 and this
in fact seems to be quite okay for black
the idea is that the night will come to
the excellent is 6 square blockading
yeah this is the possible continuation
Queen g4 and now just 96 it's not clear
if white can make substantial progress
here it's a very good thing that this
pawn has blocked an interesting and
interesting line but it's very
understandable though that by now
sweedler was getting kind of nervous
against those against those pawns it's
simply when he rejected to take on
deform them in this position here we
could have taken on deform here instead
of 98 you decided to play with fire with
black and you got fire yeah he played
Queen d7 they are now trying to - you
have to save himself with the Queen
trade and it was played and one took of
course play 96 check yeah white will
regain the piece this is just a fork but
of course we have Queens off very
important in defense of course and
blacks King while bow being exposed is
also near the critical point so it might
help to to clarify matters yeah black
played king g6 here must do that not
much not much else and in fact here
where it oh I think I forgot a little
line here what also must trade you
cannot retreat and keep the Queen's on
because of Queen f5 this is very
important you know ok so she had the
trade chat e6 and we had King d6 there's
really nothing else yeah here aronia
rather quickly
I believe took on f7 um he had an
alternative and note that he played
relatively quickly after he made his
decision early it's 40 minutes left on
the clock that's quite amazing but as
mentioned it is far more it's far easier
for white to play despite the fact that
he's a piece down most of the time
because you're the one attacking you
have the the easier job to do yeah here
took on f7 as mentioned relatively
quickly
it seems that here he had a better name
available and quite an amazing one at
that
what has the strongest Bishop f6 cm
which of course a computer is quick to
point out but it's not easy for a human
to to just to consider intermediate
moves when you just can get your piece
back that you have sacrificed before and
the capture also needs to some advantage
for what it's not like Aronian is
spoiling everything here he only had
this move which was stronger the fun
thing is that black here only has one
move to not lose immediately and this is
somewhat wacky looking move Knight g5
really strange but it's the only move
that not loses immediately what what
else could black play we can look at
some things let's start with 98 there's
just a seven and it's it's gone Bishop
e5 is also very strong
like that 1096 um black can't try this
smooth to recapture here with the rook
would be really comfortable in
comparison but the white has the strong
move Bishop h4 tending bishop g3 again
and something like that is losing very
easily yeah what here I mean look at
this piece tonight moves anywhere let's
say here check check
that's just just too much and it's
absolutely the case that black must be
in HD 5 as weird as it looks
yeah and and this is in fact not totally
lost I mean it's it's so interesting to
look at um yeah 95 what's most testing
move is actually the check I am NOT the
capture if you capture like can take on
d5 and after hmm after a seven play
rupee eight and it's not clear that this
is really really something for white I'm
I'm not totally sure because it still
looks tricky with the rook I post the
key parts of the King but I I don't I
don't really find the clear win here I
really don't yeah in fact this is an
interesting alternative the check now
king c5 must be played go here check
this is just just a bit a bit too quick
and this is where the check checks the
important thing so must go here and then
something like that is the best line
check
and it's not so clear if white is going
to win that he has very good winning
chances I believe but you cannot really
call it totally winning or anything
blacks got a pawn and potential for some
counter play but it's not clear if those
pawns how dangerous they are they cannot
be missed at the moment without losing
one or even both yeah at the end of the
day Bishop f6 was maybe somewhat
stronger and then what what he played
but it still is very difficult
okay he took on FC and a7 and now will
give fate as his right played boys good
luck
check the check King d7 and Ruby at 6 so
it has transformed to a position where
white now has an extra pawn at the pawn
on f7 that however of course is
vulnerable and will probably get lost
after rookie to only move f4 rookie 7 we
indeed get to a position where this is
being recaptured which should be 5 and
rook takes yeah you should avoid this
which losses yeah lots of material so
took here and now of course what did not
exchange rooks this would immediately
lead to a draw he wants to keep the
active rook played shank d6 check and
King to e8 and probably key is 7 is a
bit tougher but very tricky tricky again
this whole position now is exceptionally
difficult to play for for a human player
I mean
the computer of course is completely
relaxed in a way it just calculates and
but you're under so much pressure you
have no chance whatsoever to win as
black you just need to find the only
moves against those again those checks
the the running deep horn and the
dominant Bishop only five that it's very
tricky to defend their work in e8 king
e7 was maybe maybe a tougher defense
it's of course comparable to the game
but maybe slightly slightly tougher rook
e1 is something that the Dwight can can
try here and those yeah
this kind of booth that don't look to
forcing they can be exceptionally hard
to meet what should black play now for
example it could go look the age yeah
check check to f8 and d6 yeah eight
sorry and d6 yeah and why it's the
retains some pressure it's it's
difficult to say maybe rookie Sutton was
was a bit a bit more more tenacious
check but okay makini aid rookie one
this is how it was played in in the game
rookie seven this was Peters idea when
he went to aid to put the rook on e7 now
note that if black now plays King e7
White has a very strong reply at first
thought you might think okay well he
doesn't have discovered check here but
f5 in fact is very strong move in fact
just preparing a discovered check f5 is
winning a straightaway of black takes
check
check yeah this gets lost
yeah well rookie seven was was played
and now Luke see one
yeah here White had a good alternative
with Luke a one to attack the a
seven-point it's not easy at all to to
defend but it's very difficult to play
this type of position perfectly I think
our audience move is fine he just keeps
the pressure on c7 is of course a
potential square that white rook that
white rook can contain and black is
simply condemned to complete complete
yeah passivity he cannot move anything
here
nothing active inside played rook F to
f7 Bishop f6 d7 check check on e6 now
everything's false and d6 now the pawn
is on on d6 and I'm really not sure if
black still has a way to to save himself
I mean there are lines that are maybe a
bit tougher we will come to that soon
but in a practical game I think this is
almost not not defensible okay King g8
it was played and h4 very typical way to
play you want to use all your all your
units so to say and hdh pawn can be a
further tool to use to weaken blacks
position with h5 and the capture yeah
black can can just mark time ham can
dance no no active movement side um here
he played Bishop g5
ruk c7 was also a good a good
opportunity um I believe he wasn't sure
if this is really helping him because
right here the D pawn now is a C pawn
and it's not so easy to promote of
course because this is a light squared
bishop and I guess he didn't want to
yeah to play it with the C pawn rather
with a deep one that is actually upon
that promotes on a dark square which can
be supported by of their own bishop yeah
well Bishop g5 it keeps the pressure on
no doubt about that King f7 I'm Roxy to
e1 intending rook yourself
yeah and in fact here will I committed a
mistake
I will if you play droops Bishop c6
after which White has a fast win for the
first time really really fast when I
guess what he should do is King g8 it's
it's not much fun but it's probably
necessary Ruby 7 rook b8 and now the
strong move real strong whoops you wanna
yeah what is black you're supposed to do
now this is the big threat that you you
cannot really take I think you need to
take right yeah you must take I'm sorry
you must take because rooks e7 otherwise
is so strong but okay what I'm wanting
to show you is that this position for
example it's not 100% clear cut
I mean white should wind I think but
yeah note that there is some sort of
blockade on the Kings side and if you
imagine this position with rooks off I'm
not 100% sure that this would really win
but probably what black needs to do it's
not much fun but probably this is what
was the relatively best defense in this
position he played this Bishop c6 after
which Aronian played h5 very human move
but
he had a better continuation even Brooke
is seven check check Kinji eight and now
the move rook c1 was immediately winning
the game the idea being that after rook
takes d6
there is rooks e7 which is somewhat
difficult point for a human to find the
taxi six drives and intense Bishop Eason
with this very strange
yes cure is a defensive walk not sure it
wins it Winston exchanged while
retaining all other advantages into
position this was even stronger than the
hh5 moves that Aronian played but it's
probably not spoiling the win
yeah a five now was played and yeah it
seems that maybe G takes H was a bit
tougher but I don't think you will save
the game anymore
check June 8th Andrew c1 it's the same
idea as before with this strange Bishop
d6 maneuver after rook c1 here
rook t 6 Luke c7 what black can play
something like that Bishop e7 and rook
g6 and try to hang on here but it's
probably it's probably in Wayne white
can take the rooks are just too active I
don't think that this is in any way
defensible yeah okay he played aged five
and eight five after which chat check
and this capture was played like a
recaptured note that black cannot play
with d6 here after TJ King takes King h8
their strongest f5 a very typical move
intending to get the bishop over to the
long diagonal for a deadly check so very
strong
black can after this needed to recapture
and this is what he did
rook 1 to e6 yeah and this is cannot
defend this anymore ok 7 he took on g6
check and this was the final move of the
game Sevilla resigned he has no defense
anymore
rook eg-6 checking of a Droog h8 maid so
something like that check checkmate
there is a mate and it's you you don't
have any move to play like that for
example there is check this check yeah
now various ways to play but the easiest
is to just push those pawns like is
completely paralyzed him and will lose
quickly yeah so Swilly resigned and this
means that he yeah he was very close if
you look at the final moves of the
kramnik game where he was close to
winning they I could have been on +2
being the being on top of this
tournament and what is he spoiled that
ok Kramnik defended beautifully but he's
be spoiled a winning this game and here
he lost against Aronian from a position
if you look at smooth yeah this is
playing with fire think check here where
he went for this fighting move he could
have also played Knight takes d4 the
more conservative move and I don't think
he he would have lost here despite his
statement that he thought like is very
slightly worse um yeah and now he's back
to 50% so he could have been on +2
easily and now it's just 50% after four
rounds which is not the end of the world
in terms of pure score I mean
fifty percent after four rounds there's
still eight still ten rounds to go but
the psychological impact is certainly am
NOT
yeah not to be ignored
I mean swindler really am yeah Sports
bought a big chance here even even here
just the draw would have been much
better also look at Aronian score
Aronian on +1
he could've could have been just on 50%
if this game turned out to be a draw at
the end but in general a great fighting
game you cannot criticize him much for
498 it was probably an not very good
practical decision as the resulting
position is just much more easy to play
for white he just has all the fun in
this position and it's um yeah it's
objectively probably okay
but if you can so easily went go astray
it it's probably not a good choice in a
practical game he in fact defended very
very well initially I believe but when
when it came to the check this position
I mean Queen d7 just leads to a
completely thankless task and he may be
really needed to play King f8 as risky
as it is but that's that's how the game
is going to unfold if you play this 98
thing and let your self yeah expose your
King to this this this big attack
instead of exchanging Queens with 94
yeah nevertheless I hope you enjoyed
this very complicated game I actually
had a really hard time to analyze it and
please don't be angry or anything if
they are some mistake in there it's very
interesting if you have some time on
your hands to analyze a bit yourself
it's um I'm just touching the surface of
this game there are so many possible
deviations along the road
very very tough to play over the board
yeah I hope you enjoyed it I'll be back
tomorrow with round five coverage of the
candidates tournament thanks for
watching